the national security count Council on
the Department of Homeland Security they
left them vacant they dismissed the
people and never filled the slots they
were there from previous administration
the Trump budget calls for slashing
almost seven hundred million dollars
from the Center for Disease Control and
this was the budget which came out after
we knew about the coronavirus threat and
now that continues to develop our health
needs by ransacking other public health
needs whether it's the Ebola fund or
others so that was up until now now we
are trying to work in a bipartisan way
and that's one of the reasons that I was
delayed in meeting with you this morning
trying to we're coming close to a
bipartisan agreement and the Congress
says how we can go forward with a number
that is a good start but we don't know
how much we will need hopefully not so
much more because prevention will work
but nonetheless we have to be ready to
do what we need to do and in that regard
we want to make sure that the President
cannot transfer any of these new funds
this is part of the statement from
Chapman me from leader Schumer and me
the president cannot transfer any of
these new funds to anything others then
use for the coronavirus threat and that
we perhaps we'll have interest-free
loans made available to small businesses
which are suffering from the corona
virus somewhere maybe have to shut down
because of that vaccines we make sure
that the vaccines are affordable
affordable and we think it's important
to make that point because of what's
that for Terry azar said yesterday we
want we would want to ensure that we can
work to make it affordable but we can't
control the price because we need the
private sector to invest really that's
this this would be a vaccine that is
developed with the taxpayer dollars to
again prevent and we think that should
be available to everyone not dependent
on a big farm I guess yesterday when
Quartey made that ill-advised statement
he was wearing his farmer hat but she
wore before he came here and then we
want to be sure that state and local
governments are reimbursed for cost
incurred while assisting the federal
response to the corona virus outbreak
again I I met with I spoke with a vice
president this morning made some of
these concerns known to him we have
always had a very candid relationship
and I expressed to him the concern that
I had of his being this position of
while I look forward to working with him
about his when he was governor of
Indiana slashing the public health
budget having some clinics one
especially a Planned Parenthood kind of
closed which was the only place where
there in that Scott County where you
could get tested for HIV and AIDS there
was an outbreak again he will have his
side of that story but the fact is is
that the health professional the
director of the health in in Indiana at
the time Jerome Adams was the vice
president then Governor Pence's health a
state health officer he is now the
Surgeon General of the United States so
this is about their forces it's also
about personnel it's also about respect
for science for evidence-based decision
making and it's about having so much of
that talent that we are so proud of in
our public health sector be available in
other countries so that we can get a
true a true accurate true and accurate
assessment of what is happening in other
countries they may be having the best
intentions but they may not have shall
we say even with the most talent they
man they don't have the the value-added
that someone from our country could lend
so in any event with Laporte as I say to
working together
bipartisan way and hopefully you know
again in a very candid way about our
concerns about past performance or
statements that are made has put that in
perspective as we move forward to have
the adequate funding the respect for
science and evidence-based decision
making and again reimbursement for state
and local government and understanding
the impact that this has on our
community since speaking of community I
had the privilege on Monday of walk
having a walk through Chinatown I always
loved to go there I feel very proud of
it
I always feel very privileged to and say
oh my poor colleagues and they come home
they don't have the advantage of this
beautiful diversity that I have in my
district but sadly Chinatown is being
very hard hit by the lack of tourism and
the rest of the coronavirus so a number
of us went there and then he press'd
came to to have a theater go to a temple
like the candle I have a lunch dim sum
that was go visit and make fortune
cookies and fortune cookie factory
by the way fortune cookie machine which
is fabulous
is made in America and fortune cookies
are an American phenomenon it's not
something you really find in China or at
least it didn't begin there in any event
in the shops and all the rest to be able
to show confidence not fear in terms of
the virus so again in every way we want
to be fully prepared but not panicking
or fearful of what is happening then
today or tomorrow on the floor of the
house we have very important legislation
it is to stop the use of tobacco
epidemic that we're expressing also it's
the one the public health front the
house will vote on hrs two three three
nine strong legislation to combat the
growing use tobacco and e-cigarettes
crisis more than 5.3 million middle 8th
middle school and high school students
are using e-cigarettes more than twice
as many as two years ago
according to US Surgeon General Youth
cigarettes
youth is an epidemic the bill provides
protects our children with strong
measures preventing marketing to youth
under 21 banning all flavored tobacco
products including menthol cigarettes
and e-cigarettes big tobacco is just on
its usual rampage it uses flavors like
gummy bear bubblegum and cotton to
ensnare and addicting to tobacco
ninety-seven percent of youth using
e-cigarettes use flavored cigarettes so
here we are with this bill would reduce
health disparities that spring from
cigarette smoking and this is something
a statement that was put out by the
National Medical Association which is
African American doctors the the
National black Nurses Association
the n-double-a-cp black women's health
imperative the association of black
cardiologists the African American
tobacco control Leadership Council the
list goes on and on there are 75
organizations representing public health
of communities of color and teachers in
support of the bill from the AMA
American Academy of Pediatrics to
National Association of school nurses
the Society of the thoracic thoracic
surgeons again affecting lung cancer and
this statement says to Congress and the
sale of flavored cigarette tobacco
products including menthol cigarettes
and flavored e-cigarettes support HR
23:39 to protect our kids it really I
don't know if you've seen this statement
let me read it for decades big tobacco
is targeted african-americans with
menthol cigarettes with devastating
consequences menthol cigarettes have
addicted generations of African
Americans resulting in high death rates
from lung cancer heart disease stroke
and other smoking-related illnesses 7
out of 10
african-american youth smokers smoke
menthol making them more likely to
become addicted smokers today the
tobacco industry is using e-cigarettes
to hook a new generation with flavors
like bubble gum mint mango and menthol
it is a public health crisis affecting
over 1.5 3 million kids
the n-double-a-cp the National Medical
Association the black Doc's the National
black Nurses Association but wouldn't
health imperative association of black
cardiologists the list goes on and on
I repeat those who ever signed on to
this so we're hoping to have a good vote
tomorrow on that and today's a very sad
day for us because it was one year ago
today that we passed HR 8 and send it
over to to the Senate
HR 8th is our legislation as you know
for common-sense background check
background checks and it is it's very
sad that the Grim Reaper has decided
that more people will die because he
it's the Grim Reaper 100 people a day my
understanding is our die from gun
violence not all of them can be saved by
this legislation but then he could so
the we did HR 8 today one year and then
tomorrow HR 1112
the South Carolina loophole that enabled
a hate crime to be performed at mother
Emanuel Church while this would close
that loophole mr. Clyburn spell so here
we are 90% of the public support
common-sense background checks Democrats
Republicans independents gun owners
because most of them have engaged in
background checks this would be only a
simple matter I've expanded to sales on
the Internet issues that gun shows the
gun the internet sales have been have
come about more abundantly since the
bill was originally passed so this is
only an expansion of all of that and we
would hope that we could save lives for
doing that
anyway I have some other things to talk
about perhaps we can do it in the Q&A
any questions my I've been very clear in
all of this our responsibility is to win
the house we had know how to win we've
demonstrated that and the most
gerrymandered voters suppress political
arena you can name and yet we net gained
40 seats in the last election by owning
the ground with our mobilization not
yielding one grain of sand by a message
of bold progressive agenda was a
mainstream and and non menacing and
having the money the m's I don't know to
to advance our cause with our message in
our ground game that was very well
managed by Ben ray Lujan and now
continues to be well managed by Cheri
Bustos our chair and a most important
part of it
all those MS are the members to be our
candidates they're absolutely
spectacular
my responsibilities to make sure that
those we elected last time return to
Congress keep the majority and add to
our numbers the presidential is its own
race and I don't contrary to what you
may be hearing or writing we are not
getting we are all unified whoever the
nominee is of our party we will
wholeheartedly support our gospel is one
of unity unity unity so I I don't have
that the experience that you may have
described about hearing from anybody I
just would like to ask somebody who
usually comes to our meetings Chad just
to reward those not those who parachute
in for the something yes yet
[Music]
well we'll see as you indicate there's a
deadline we want to have it done by the
middle of will March 12 for us from a
legislative standpoint but March 15th is
the deadline and we have the challenge
and this is my you know my wheelhouse if
I was there fully for only some of the
five so provisions in the past the the
goal is to have the right balance
between civil liberties and national
security I think the bill that was put
together in the Judiciary Committee
working with the Intelligence Committee
does that there are others who would
like to see some other provisions were
just working through that now of respect
for everyone's point of view but it is
really important that we pass the FISA
bill one thing that I'm very happy about
because this has been just a painful
experience for all these years is that
we will have an end to the data
collection telephone by telephone
records etc so that will be out will
there many good things that are in the
bill that protect and further protect
civil liberties and I would hope that we
can come to a conclusion on it depends
it's not it's a postponement and we'll
just go through anytime somebody has a
suggestion what does it mean in terms of
civil liberties and national security
and so we'll see how that goes
hopefully that will will be done
expeditiously here on the hill and on
the White House when you are delivering
messages about Burma well we are hoping
to work in a bipartisan way to stop the
the spread to have serious prevention
science-based evidence-based
decision-making with professionals who
know the the territory of science and
epidemiology to do the job the the
market drop now it's what 3,000 2,500
but as of last night 3,000 is disturbing
but again we wanted still confidence we
want to prevent without panicking people
about this but the market will do what
it does with the invisible hand that it
always does it does show some fragility
on the part of the market that it would
drop so much but again it can't affect
what we do with what we're there to do
is to prevent and not panic people on
the subject a president said something
so strange that you really have to
wonder he said the reason the market
dropped is because of the debate the
other night well the market had dropped
18 hundred points before the debate the
other night the market dropped while he
was speaking yesterday in his press
conference so you know let's not let's
not be silly about what that is that the
clearly the lack of ability to get some
of the the product to sell and the rest
has an impact on the bottom line of some
of these companies we don't like seeing
the market drop that's for sure we hope
that this will have a turnaround but it
cannot at set
how we address the issue where our issue
is public health our issue is prevention
and we would hope that that would not
lower the market but raise the market
because we want to show that decisions
have made to put this in good hands now
that's not what the purpose of the
meeting is this is strictly don't read
too much into it and your moments this
is a help a strictly a housekeeping
meeting this is to say this is a date
like March 7th coming up is when the
names will be sent to the state parties
as to who the unpledged delegates are
this is about when how we participate in
committees and the rest it's really just
a reading of the rules it's not anything
about that and that the rules are very
clear the person who will be nominated
for president will be the person who
will have a majority of the votes in
addition to that though I will take the
opportunity to to say what I said over
and over again we're responsible to win
the House of Representatives and that is
what we intend to do with our
mobilization with our messaging with our
resources in order to win and hopefully
that victory will also help to win the
Senate and to help win the White House
we also want to help to win state and
local government positions as well with
our our demonstration that we know how
to win so that's not what that meeting
is about you know what that's not that's
not this the person who will be
nominated will be the person who has a
majority plus one that may happen before
they even get to the convention but
we'll see the people will speak and
that's what we're listening to and it's
a pretty exciting thing but that's not
what this meeting is about don't read
too much into it it's merely
housekeeping just say
this is this is how you can be on a
committee this is when you get a chance
to vote what do you call them um
unpledged delegates can vote for vice
president on the first ballot
just technicalities like I'm reading of
the rule says nothing it's not political
and that's not the rules say you have a
majority plus one yes ma'am that's how
we win the house I'm talking about the
House of Representatives well I think
that Senator health care is the most
important issue in the campaign
there are three issues health care
health care and health care that's why
part one of our agenda and have we won
the election last time was to lower the
cost of health care by lowering the cost
of prescription drugs second was to
build bigger paychecks by building the
infrastructure of America in a green way
and the third was cleaner government on
the first two I think we can find some
common ground to work with the
administration on lowering the cost of
prescription drugs I hope so
building the infrastructure of America I
hope so
cleaner government not so but that's
where we are now that is not unusual for
the party platform or the candidates for
president to have their own agenda that
they would put forth and it's not
unusual for the House of Representatives
to have its agenda as well we have to
win in certain particular areas we're
not about a popular vote in the country
or in particular states in terms of the
electoral college
we are district by district and that's
how we won last time we demonstrated
that we know how to win
and purchase in that victory continues
the momentum is there to help us win
other positions as well when we win
would put everything on the table have a
discussion and see where we go from here
but it's not about causing any division
as we go forward unity unity unity
whoever our nominee is we will support
with respect for his or her positions
and hopefully with their respect for our
positions as well so we have made a
decision to win and as I say to the
members if you make a decision to win
you have to make every subsequent
decision to win no friction no nothing
to stay on the path to victory because
it's so very important our country is a
great country it's a great country it's
so resilient that it could even
withstand one term of donald trump two
terms and the damage that he's doing to
the rule of the law the court system in
our country the air our children breathe
the denial of of climate and the rest
just a time will take a toll so it's
absolutely essential that we win whoever
the nominee is will have our
wholehearted support
unity unity unity we've made a decision
to win thank you all very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now I owe me an all-female firm as
mikanos Olympia this time agency boy
they've chosen to follow another contest
last abuse
[Music]
[Music]